大家好,我是火厨
这期视频会简单说一个我用在石盘的策略
然后拿这个策略当例子,聊聊过你何
希望能解决大家这方面的问题吧
咱们开始
策略的规则非常简单
还是只做多
当MACD时差之后
价格突破唐契安上轨就入场
离场用固定的百分比离场
再加两个附加小条件
一个是要求MACD时差之后
如果超过了多少坑K线
仍然没有突破唐奇安上轨
那这单就取消
另一个条件是
在周五晚上
如果还有持仓
就清仓
不论盈亏
回主图
咱们看例子
先使差
突破上轨做多
然后百分比止损
再来一个
先使差
突破上轨做多
然后周五清仓
再找一个成功的例子
先使差
再突破
最后百分比止盈
参数也都是很随意的
唐奇安用25
MACD就是默认的12 26 9
看到这可能很多人会觉得
你这个策略也太普通了吧
就是看着各项指标都一般
曲线也不差好看
还不如我平时弄出来的那些
那为什么这个人要拿它做试盘
接下来聊的这个过你和可能会给出答案
我们经常会听到一些关键词
后视镜历史数据无法结实未来的市场动向指标都是滞后的还有你这些都是棍你和但如果咱们静下来仔细观察一下会发现说出这些言论的
婉转点说的话
都是些不那么成功的交易者
他们当中有些是完全没有接触过两话
有些是接触了点两话
但门槛还没摸着
撞了一头包又回去手动的
那加上他们数量庞大
又经验丰富
当然主要是亏钱的经验
就让他们说出这些话的时候信心十足
仿佛就是一种真理一样
这会让那些刚做量化的朋友
就是非常的困惑
然后迷惘甚至有些焦虑
担心自己努力的方向都是错的
之前就有不少粉丝
有私下里问过我
就是怎么找参数
还有怎么避免过你喝
我并没有说很多
只是给一些简单的建议
或者是让他们不用担心
那这次视频我就会稍微详细点说
然后也会给出一个简单的具体的解决方案
尽量陪大家一起过这个坎
上个视频分享了一个找参数的小插件
用没办法的办法解决了找参数的问题
那找到了最好的参数之后
咱们就该解决过拟合的问题了
这是一个验证的过程
验证是不是过拟合了
流程就三个步骤
也是非常简单
咱们开始尽量细
第一步
当有了一个策略之后多少都要调整一下参数然后让它适应当前的品种和周期。为了在一开始就避免过年和,找参数的时候,咱们可以不用完整的历史数据,
例如,掐头去尾,也可以留下距离现在最近几年的历史数据,至少留一年吧,
作为一个验证,看例子,我这个策略用的是十年的数据,
但找参数只用了中间的6年
也就是16年到22年
找到参数之后
再用14到16
22到24的数据来验证
看看找到的参数
能不能适应过去和未来
要求可以根据自己的情况
在我这儿
我要求它是正收益
如果验证的部分曲线不好看
都是朝下的
那基本就是过你和可以淘汰掉了
第二步
比第一步还简单
就是切换一下时间周期
要求自己的策略在不同的周期都能是正收益
跨度不用很大
四倍以内就行
要求也是看个人
还是看例子
我的这个策略呢
是在一小时周期顶上建立的
现在用15分钟
30分钟
4小时都验证一下
我来切换一下周期
然后15分钟的
30分钟的
4小时的
还行
如果这关没过的
也可以淘汰掉
第三步
找一两个正相关的品种来做验证
我策略这个品种没什么正相关的所以可以忽略虽然在其他品种上跑的也挺好甚至有粉丝花了不到十分钟在大饼上就搞出来了这样的曲线
扯远了
那什么是正相关的
举个例子
如果开发的策略是用在大饼上的
那同样的事物中在二饼上也不能太差
如果策略是用在欧美货币队上的
那在傍美上也得差不多才行
大概就是这样了
经过这三个步骤
基本上大部分没那么扛揍的策略
就已经被淘汰了
看着很简单
但是第一步我们做的是一个样本内
样本外的开发
换一个说法就是
机器学习里总提到的训练级
验证级和测试级
但例子省了一级
第二三步是一个交叉验证的测试
这也是非常有效实用的开发步骤
这几步就差不多完成了一个策略
在上线之前
前三分之一或者四分之一的部分
对后面还有非常多的测试
但对于现在只用TV和小查件的朋友来说
能简单完成的测试也就这些
所以又是一个没办法的办法
看到这大家可能已经明白了
如果自己的策略经过了合理的开发
测试验证
那它的适应性就会非常强
然后非常的扛揍
也就不需要担心什么过你和的问题
视频演示的策略
是经过了更多的后续测试
然后保留下来的
现在看的是不是也就没有那么普通了
最后还是祝大家都能找到自己喜欢的策略
再见